mom went so far to get me in second to
mrs. dipplewhite him they say a cat are
kinships out
oh whoa okay going on and he cuts his
Perot
it's been a tough game oh love aren't
you whoa that's a good Kinkos of thing
The Telegraph now they're going to try
and do Dignitas has been acting much
better in second they get the kill with
a Beckett Brno the insect is a play so
famous it immortalized the name of the
player who first pulled it off
some moments in eSports are famous in
isolation standing as monuments to the
skill and passion of the players while
having little impact on the scene itself
others however have a lasting and
dramatic impact not only on the
professional scene but on the wider game
as a whole such as the case for the
insect it happened on May 24th 2013 at
all-star Shanghai in the blink of an eye
choy insect in suck changed everything
they're gonna change that is the magic
element
by queuing to yellow Pete from out of
vision before placing a ward W into it
and kicking Pete back into the waiting
arms of his team insect won the team
fight before it even started some of you
might be thinking that's it that's the
insect and yes four years later the play
does look commonplace but at the time it
was revolutionary normally its flash
picks it was Ward kicks that was awesome
it few if any had ever seen such a play
pulled off in soloqueue let alone on a
professional stage and it blew the
collective minds of the community the
maneuver demanded a level of mechanical
skill and execution beyond not only what
had been expected from a pro player but
what was considered possible on lease in
it was branded the insect overnights wow
it went so far to get the insect on the
but who do it insect kick some back
they're going to try and do Dignitas has
been acting much better
since then the play has been replicated
modified and improved upon by pros and
casual players alike the insect
transcends the single match it comes
from it has become a part of League of
Legends as a whole there's in sec the
very classic well known queue twice war
jump behind kick them into your team in
many ways this moment is a turning point
in the trajectory of professional league
of legends the expectation for
mechanical skill took a sharp uptick
after this moment and pushed the speed
and split-second gameplay of high-level
League of Legends like never before but
hand in hand with that change the insect
is a watershed moments in League of
Legends it embodies a paradigm shift and
approach to the game the end of one way
of thinking of a league and the
beginning of another against TSM I
queued on double if and then I connected
the queue flash behind him and then he
reacted and flash behind me and he went
out of kick range and I didn't get the
kickoff we got three to zero that team
play and is really big turning point in
the game but if I are flashed I would
have kicked them into 19 we probably
would want to fight and while it's
difficult to lay all those changes at
the feet of this one moment in league
history there's something about the
insect that resonates to this day and so
the next time your favorite jungler
pulls off a play like this which are -
this inhibitor
I try it 41 city kids back to the front
line they found him if sentences got
like young cannot do wrong this game you
can think in sec for showing the world
just how far the game and its players
could be pushed towards greatness thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button